[Musique]
qui n'a jamais rêvé de vivre une double
vie de se faire passer pour un autre
d'être autorisé à mentir tout en étant
pleinement acteurs de la marche du monde
ce quotidien c'est celui des officiers
de renseignement de la direction
générale de la sécurité extérieure la
dgse des anonymes qui s'affairent dans
les coulisses de l'histoire pour
défendre les intérêts français
le destin peu commun de ces soldats de
l'ombre constitue le secret le mieux
gardé de l'état français presque rien et
sus de leur mission de leur véritable
identité de l'ordinaire de ces femmes et
de ces hommes et ce souvent bien
longtemps après qu'ils aient quitté
leurs fonctions
cette existence hors norme a récemment
été popularisé par la série d'eric
rochant le bureau des légendes diffusée
sur canal + depuis avril 2015
première fiction française à avoir eu
accès à la véritable boîte du boulevard
mortier
le bureau des légendes nous dévoile un
univers froid très éloignés des
habituels fantasmes associés à
l'espionnage du recrutement au retour de
mission la série offre une plongée dans
cette existence solitaire périlleuse au
plus près des enjeux sécuritaires
contemporain à quoi ressemble la
véritable vie des espions français
quelle est la part de fiction dans ce
quotidien hors norme
j'ai consacré plusieurs années de ma vie
à cette dernière question
j'en ai même fait une thèse de
philosophie à la sorbonne consacré à la
fiction d'espionnage je voulais vous
faire partager ce monde que j'ai eu la
chance d'entrevoir pendant toutes ces
années de recherche
je suis pauline beeston et vous écoutez
espion une vie sous légende
aujourd'hui premier épisode
l'entrée dans la clandestinité
j'ai vu une photo de vous me dites pas
suivre jour je suis marié loiseau
c'est un honneur rare chance deux ans
mon comptoir des costards bull n'ont pas
pu savoir
un grand veste chemise rose et un type
besoin jean tout en parfait je voudrais
leur nom prénom profession numéro de
portable
je vous donne un quart d'heure pour moi
mathieu kassovitz acteurs un clan des
c'est quelqu'un qui devrait pas être là
et pour les séries c'est quelqu'un qui
doit être là vous allez apprendre à
rapprocher des gens tout en gardant la
bonne distance ni trop loin pour en
savoir le plus possible ni trop près
pour le pain influence la cellule votre
mission c'est de connaître les gens sans
vous faire remarquer vous n'êtes pas
rageant nous excluons destin un agent
clandestins donc c'est un agent qui est
envoyé à l'étranger
sara giraudeau actrice temps veiller sur
le terrain pour rencontrer des gens et
approcher des potentielles sources pour
petits tapis pouvoir envoyer des
informations à la dgse sur ces sources
et à un moment donné obtenir des
informations en tout cas intéressante
pour la dgse mais par sous les jambes
parce que faut absolument pas qu'on
sache qui il est et est donc ayons et
joue un rôle clan distancer quelqu'un
donc florence loiret caille actrice qui
est sur le terrain qui opère sous les
jambes c'est à dire que hélas une fausse
identité
généralement un travail qui est qui est
le sien ça peut être traducteur
professeur de français
sismologue comme marina loiseau il faut
que la légende coll
euros enfin capacités professionnelles
des gens et ensuite sur le terrain il
s'agit effectivement d'approcher des
cibles seraient susceptibles de sa boîte
quoi ça c'est à l'adar notre cible
depuis deux mois
gêné en clair on est en train d'établir
la liste à des renseignements auxquelles
il peut avoir accès pour le moment elles
correspondent bien aux tristes aux deux
courses on en a besoin on a complété
avant de vous la soumettre si on veut
obtenir de ces personnes des
renseignements camille de castelnau
scénariste pour ça il faut bien
connaître les personnes et parfois bien
les connaître intimement
enfin quand je dis intimement ça veut
pas du tout dire je savais que ça veut
dire
[Musique]
les connaître connaître leur
personnalité en fait et leurs points
faibles qui sont général eu l'argent
légaux parfois mais je pense de moins en
moins ça doit dépendre des pays mais
parfois un vice caché
[Musique]
c'est en agissant sur les points faibles
qu'on peut manipuler les gens et leur
demander plus ou moins directement
d'ailleurs de fournir du renseignement
le renseignement humain qu'on oppose
renseignements disant numérique digital
et technologique
eric rochant créateur et showrunner
passe en général aussi pourvu par la
clandestinité puisqu'il faut soutirer
des informations à des gens qui ne
veulent pas les données des informations
qui sont importantes pour le pays et
donc il faut leur soutirer d'une
certaine manière en général sans qu'ils
sachent qu'ils descendent en train de
donner donc sans les vols soit on les
pousse à les communiquer bon et ça ça
demande évidemment la conditionnalité
mais le bureau de légende c'est un peu
plus large étant une série sur le
renseignement
c'est une série quand même qu'ils
abordent cette idée de la
conditionnalité du masque du leurre du
mensonge et du secret événements
[Musique]
le secret c'est ce qui est séparé hélène
l'oeil et philosophe et psychanalyste
c'est ce qui est mis à l'écart donc
l'action secrète c'est l'action qui est
parallèle qui n'entrent pas dans les
grands cadre de la politique ça semble
rejoindre exactement à synonyme de la
clandestinité
à ceci près que la clandestinité ça
vient quand même d'un adverbe latin
clame qui veut dire cacher et qui vient
du verbe seller donc le clandestin si
celui qui ce cd qui est sous scellés
donc il ya vraiment dans la
clandestinité
une idée qu'il n'ya pas exactement dans
celle de secret qui est le cas chez
l'action secrète de l'état si elle
suppose des opérations clandestines se
sont forcément et bien des opérations
qui se situe pas en marge de la légalité
dans les états que nous connaissons
puisque c'est l'état qui s'en porte
garant mais disons qu'ils obligent à
avoir recours à des choses qui pour les
citoyens sont illégales comme j'ai
d'identité dissimuler son apparence
comme nous à faire effectivement un
clandestin et la carte d'identité
j'ai pas trouvé comment c'est possible
j'ai deux grosses malles en petite
affaire je n'ai pas encore tout déballé
donc de charteau je leur vin ok vin
d'autres non tout est là à nous alors
on va tout vérifier l'adresse mail et
lefebvre at gmail.com ok n'existe plus
la clandestinité c'est un mode
opératoire un moyen qui permet de cacher
les actions d'un service de
renseignement damien vente puis velde
chercheurs donc la clandestinité ça
contribue au secret mais c'est pas
exactement le secret être la
clandestinité sa pluie de manière
pratique sur une légende c'est à dire se
créer une nouvelle vie elle s'appuie
aussi sur une couverture info métier de
préférence quelque chose d'assez banal
et un métier en rapport avec
l'environnement dans lequel le
clandestin où l'agent illégal va
travailler c'est un mode opératoire qui
sert deux types d'activités spécifiques
quand on parle d'activités de
renseignement
d'une part la collecte d'informations
protéger plus particulièrement à travers
le renseignement opérationnel et le
renseignement humain et d'autre part les
activités qui visent à influencer l'état
du monde de manière plus directe ce
qu'on appelle en france les actions
clandestines
je pense qu'il est important de noter
dès le départ que la clandestinité c'est
vraiment un mode opératoire qui
s'applique à certaines activités de
renseignement mais certainement pas
toutes les activités de renseignement et
que donc quand on parle de clandestinité
on parle vraiment d'une relativement
petite partie de ce que font les
services de renseignement il ne faudrait
pas penser que cette zone secrète de
l'état des services dits secret ne fasse
que des opérations clandestines
il ya tout un travail sur le
renseignement ouvert comme on dit qui ne
se fait pas de manière ouverte parce que
là encore il faut pas montrer qu'on
s'intéresse quand on s'intéresse à ceux
qui vont agir sous couverture avec des
faux papiers avec des faux noms avec une
légende de sont quand même relativement
au moins nombreux plus haute
jean guisnel journaliste c'est à dire ce
sont des gens qui dans le cours de leur
carrière vont avoir des périodes dans
lesquelles ils sont clandestins voir
pour ceux qui appartiennent à certaines
entités du service comme la direction
des opérations vont être plus
clandestins que les autres si vous avez
un agent de la direction du
renseignement qui part travailler dans
une ambassade pour quelques temps
où il va avoir une fausse identité le
temps de sa mission et puis après il
reviendra aux choses classiques les gens
qui appartiennent à la direction des
opérations et au service actions vont
beaucoup plus souvent avoir recours
l'identité fausses ou à la falsification
intégral sur leur personnalité
c'est plus fréquent là à ma connaissance
c'est ça se passe à la baisse'
anciennement la direction des opérations
et sans doute aussi à la direction du
renseignement
quand un clandestin fait sa mission
exécute sa mission pour le compte du des
services spéciaux il est une personne
avec pour principes de base qu'on ne
leur lit pas au gouvernement français
alors maintenant celui qui fait une
mission ponctuelle ou celle qui fait une
mission ponctuelle va être envoyée sur
un terrain pour un temps donné va
prendre une identité fossé puis vallar
ans après et puis vous en avez qui sont
infiltrés qui ont des vies entières
complètement masqué qui agissent à
l'étranger et qui vivent en france sous
leur identité fausses ou si la
clandestinité sereine invisible en fait
qu'ils essaieraient de faire changer le
cours de l'histoire
alexandre papa emmanuel cherche ça
serait évidemment de transformer
peut-être un certain équilibre du monde
sans jamais qu'on puisse remonter à la
source du qui fait quoi à la
clandestinité c'est de peine se faire
prendre la main dans le sac
ces deux d'agir derrière un écran de
fumée
c'est induit un certain nombre d'actions
c'est à dire que on va agir avec des
proxys des intermédiaires on va essayer
de couper en fait le lien entre celui
qui a fait celui qui a pris la décision
est donc la clandestinité ça passe par
plein de cheveux sa place par des hommes
et des femmes qui sont déployés en
dehors de nos frontières
on le voit très bien dans la série avec
les risques que cela peut avoir c'est
aussi déployé des moyens technologiques
c'est aussi un objet fort en terme
d'image c'est le drone qu'on doit pas
entendre qu'on ne doit pas voir qui
survole en permanence et donc c'est tous
ces outils en fait qu'ils sont mis en
commun qu'ils soient humains
technologiques avec une ambition c'est
finalement préservé les intérêts d'un
état c'est pouvoir agir en dehors de nos
frontières
préserver
un moyen d'action et une certaine
autonomie voilà ça répond à la nécessité
de l'état alors bien entendu on entre là
sur un terrain qui est tout à fait mine
et puisque une manière juridique de
pensée est toujours à l'affût des
opérations clandestines que mène l'état
puisque elle relève cette fois delà de
la décision d'agir à l'avant ce qui
suppose bien entendu que l'action qui
est menée pour cela soit elle-même
clandestina
[Musique]
comment les clandestins sont ils
recrutaient ya deux possibilités ou bien
c'est une personne qui appartient à
l'univers civile ou bien c'est une
personne qui appartient à l'univers
militaire donc d'abord ces gens vont
intégrer le service de la dgse dans
lequel ils vont pouvoir avoir des
quantités d'activité des quantités de
spécialités qui n'appelle pas
nécessairement être officiellement un
clandestin les qualités recherchées
c'est les qualités qu'on recherche dans
plein de profession il faut certainement
avoir une propension aux déguisements
enfin là la dissimulation que n'importe
qui n'est pas forcément à tout le monde
n'est pas n'est pas fan de ce genre de
2,2 de fonctionnement mais il faut
certainement ça et puis après il faut
des vrais qualités de curiosité de
discrétion de sens de l'état
ça me paraît être des critères de loyer
ne pas s'affoler de passes tomber en âge
quand il ya un problème de pas et de
parents rougir à la moindre émotion de
pavot là mais il ya des gens qui peuvent
le faire et on a d'autres qui peuvent
pas peut-être que ces gens là sont pas
faits pour être des agents secrets
je pense que la dgse et n'importe quel
service des renseignements cherche
l'excellence dans tous les domaines dont
elle a besoin de se servir donc que ce
soit des bosses des domaines techniques
technologiques des domaines d'expertisé
domaine de savoir bon voila et aider
aussi des domaines physique puisqu'il ya
service action dont il ya des gens qui
sont qui sont spécialisés dans l'action
je pense que la dgse est capable de
recruter des gens qui n'ont aucun
diplôme mais qui sont considérés comme
étant excellent dans leur domaine
ce qui est intéressant en discutant avec
quelques personnes de la dgs ces deux de
réaliser qu en fait un risque un danger
un vrai défaut que pourrait affronter un
service de renseignements c'est le
dogmatisme le dogmatisme empêche d'être
excellent donc lutter contre le
dogmatisme à tous les niveaux que ce
soit au niveau des analyses au niveau
des débats au niveau des brainstormings
au niveau évidemment
des décisions et au niveau du
recrutement c'est très important
le renseignement est un service qui est
rendu à l'état ou à ceux qui sont les
clients du renseignement en général
c'est l'état les ministères mais des
mets d des entreprises aussi peuvent
avoir besoin de renseignements les des
particuliers bon donc le renseignement
c'est un service alors pour rendre ce
service le mieux possible
il est nécessaire je crois de s'appuyer
sur une vision dogmatique du monde dans
le bureau des gens je pense que ce qui
les motive pas c'est le patriotisme déjà
après je pense qu'on choisit pas à ce
métier là ni par hasard ni uniquement
pour des belles raisons je pense que
c'est aussi probablement des structures
psychiques un peu particulière
évidemment très différente à chaque fois
il ya pas un profil type je pense mais
c'est quand même des gens que ça
intéresse ou que ça amuse ou pour qui
c'est indispensable d'avancer masqué
quoi d'avancé cacher et donc ça je pense
que tout le monde ne veut pas le faire
et tout le monde ne peut pas le faire
jeter les uns
comment ça je suis pas m'interroger
c'était bien sympa les claques tous
vous êtes résistante je me rappelle plus
très bien comment on a pu imaginer les
scènes de formation de marine danoise
aux mais en fait moi j'ai quand même une
expérience un peu longue de la création
d'art hâtives sur sur ce genre de choses
puisque j'ai j'ai fait les patriotes
angers en particulier un film qui était
sur le mossad et qui est en 91 92 prix
là il ya des scènes de formation aussi
celle là je les avais lu dans les livres
écrits par des anciens agents du mossad
donc voilà si je me suis inspiré de
s'appuie ensuite l'imagination travail
voilà c'est pas la première fois que
j'écrivais cette formation d'agent quand
je me suis mis en contact avec la dgse
pour les prévenir que j'allais faire une
série sur le dg sa g a pris
effectivement qu'il m'avait à la bonne
puisque il appréciait les patriotes et
en particulier il fait quelques extraits
du film étaient soumis aux apprentis
agents pour servir de base à la
transmission d'une technique servir de
base comme ça un peu de manière
intéressante et amusante et par contre
ils n'ont pas voulu me dire que c'est
secret défense ils ont pas voulu venir
quels extraits du film était projeté
voilà c'est oui c'est que cette
formation a assez rude quoi mais c'est
voilà pas d'affect
voilà nos affects jamais enfin essayez
du moins sur le sur le terrain on peut
être
amené à rencontrer des gens et
effectivement que la distance entre la
cible est l'agent ne soit pas forcément
c'est un peu un peu floue parfois sans
frontières quoi ça arrive ça fait partie
du métier et cc je pense que c'est ça
aussi qui l'intéressent eric rochant
c'est comment on laisse ces gens là se
démène avec des obstacles mais qui sont
la manipulation à violence c'est très
très romanesque justement ça qui fait
aussi la puissance de numéro vous avez
deux cercles
le premier c'est pour les amis le
deuxième c'est possible ces deux cercles
ne doivent jamais se rencontrer nos amis
restent des amis les cibles vous pouvez
lui faire ami avec elle mais ce ne sont
pas des amis ça veut dire quoi
que vous pouvez détruire leurs vies en
une minute sans état d'âme
vous les aimez pas vous nous apprécier
pas vous n'avez pas pitié d'eux et
peuvent vous aimez et toi vous aimez et
vous ce sont vos proies
marie jeanne elle est là une manière
d'enseigner qui sera la manière de
marinade de travail est en fait un temps
que clandestins c'est à dire c'est
d'être toujours dans l'évocation de
quelque chose sans le nommer est de
toujours contournées c'est à dire qu'il
ya cette manière de d'expliquer les
choses où tu va amener l'autre toujours
à comprendre comme le psychanalyste oui
vous amène toujours à comprendre vous
même le raisonnement sans qu'il vous le
donne en fait donc elle va elle va juste
donner les éléments nécessaires
avec même des petite pirouette pour que
votre esprit se met en route d'une
certaine manière et mais qui trouve
lui-même les raisonnements sait ce
qu'est vraiment douloureux moi je trouve
dans ce métier parce que c'est le seul
point sur lequel je me suis dit
justement moi là l inverse de si j'étais
marina je pense que la chose que je ne
pourrais absolument pas à gérer c'est ce
point là c'est dur de réussir à mettre à
mettre une muraille sur l'affect et ça
c'est des choses qui sont extrêmement
difficiles parce qu'on nous amène à se
déshumaniser moi je trouve que marina
loiseau a un côté très jeanne d'arc bat
déjà par sa féminité par ta jeunesse par
son apparente candeur par sa coupe de
cheveux après c'est un peu un animal à
sang froid quand même pour moi marina
l'oiseau mais évidemment oui évidemment
le dire maîtriser ses affects ce qu'il
ya de plus difficile alors après elle
est formée elle n'y arrive pas toujours
complètement et puis maîtriser son
affect ça veut pas dire ne jamais être
affecté c'est pas du tout la même chose
par exemple saison deux camps chat pour
et arrêtez et torturez et c'est vrai que
les services iraniens les met en
présence elle elle voit quand même ce
garçon pour qui elle avait de la
sympathie faim et qui est dans un état
pas possible à cause d'elle elle en est
évidemment affectée mais l'affect doit
toujours s'effacer devant la raison
d'état quoi comme tous les clandestins
ce qui est très important c'est de
savoir compartimentée cloisonnée en fait
c'est là un peu l'art du cloisonnement
en plus pour mentir et pour vivre comme
ça souvent il faut mettre un peu de
vérité dans le mensonge
je pense par exemple que c'est très
compliqué
d'être proche de quelqu'un qu'on déteste
vraiment humainement ça je pense qu'on
peut faire semblant jusqu'à un certain
point mais je pense qu'on peut un peu
envoyer à l'abattoir des gens qu'on
trouve sympathique
par ailleurs ce qui est quand même très
particulier
mais voilà on le fait en sachant
pourquoi on fait donc ça a du sens
[Musique]
d'après ce que j'ai compris le profilage
d'un impétrants à la dgse est très très
lourd et passe par un examen
psychologique de ses capacités et on m'a
raconté une histoire que j'ai trouvé
très intéressante c'est que parmi les
gens vous pensez bien ils sont ils vont
bientôt être 7000 agents au service
donc il ya eu sept mille profil
psychologique et puis vous avez un turn
over relativement important et parmi ces
gens qui passait obligatoirement des
gens qui ont des problèmes qui serait
gérable dans une entreprise normale mais
qui a déjà se pose des difficultés il ya
des gens qui peuvent pas assumer les
conflits des gens qui peuvent pas
assumer le stress des gens qui vont être
parano des gens qui vont être tout tout
tout est possible un gars qu'est ou une
fille qui aime bien boire son petit coup
que nous ça pose aucun problème et qui
vire alcoolique c'est des choses comme
ça donc que j'ai cru comprendre nous qui
pouvait pas assumer des missions
difficiles ou qu'ils avaient pu mener
bien leur mission
mais qui s'en remettaient pas ensuite eh
bien on m'a dit que parmi les gens qui
ruent les problèmes à la dgse
la quasi totalité avaient été décelées
dans le profil psychologique de l'
embauche
dans le recrutement ça c'est très
important et ça c'est évoquer aussi on
fait attention à ne pas recruter de
pervers ça a pas trop de jouissance ou
salée quand ils disent à un moment donné
là encore je ne sais plus dans quel
saison dans quel épisode mais patriotes
mais pas fanatique patriotes mais pas
fanatique ça veut dire pas de pervers
pas quelqu'un qui va jouir trop de
l'action secrète c'est ça un soldat
c'est quelqu'un qui fait des choses qui
peuvent être palpitante mais qui doit
rester ascétique pas trop en jouir parce
que sinon ça veut dire qu'il est pervers
ce que j'ai découvert en allant à la
dgse en découvrant les les gens qui
travaillent là bas
jules chagot acteurs c'est le
patriotisme et qui était en fait une
notion moi je ne connais pas du tout
enfin je pensais pas que c'était quelque
chose qui pouvait être de l'ordre d'un
sentiment chose qu'on ressent soit
profondément pour la france des choses
comme ça moi je n'ai jamais eu j'ai
jamais et éduqué avec ses idées et je
pense que le patriotisme c'est ça qui
est je trouve ça très beau en fait de
devoir ce qui habitait ces gens en tout
cas ils ont quelque chose oui de la une
fois mathieu amalric acteurs d'une foire
dans quoi est ce que c'est la patrie pas
sûr
je sais même pas maintenant si c'est
vraiment la france
je pense que c'est des valeurs je pense
que clairement les clandestins ya
quelque chose comme ça il ya une loyauté
et il ya un dévouement total pour l'état
pour la france pourquoi ils sont là en
fait et je pense que c'est ça aussi il
ya une espèce de d'addiction à un moment
donné à ça parce que de se dévouer
complètement pour la patrie pour l'état
ya eu quelque chose assez grisant de se
dire que quelque part on existants
n'existe presque plus pour nous on
n'existe que pour servir mais il faut
effectivement dénature je pense
extrêmement pour faire ça sur des années
parce que je sais que je pense qu'il ya
des clandestins qui font ça juste de
temps en temps condé mission
particulière sur un temps donné
mais là dans le bureau des légendes ont
mais on met en scène ont décrit des
clandestins qui sont qui font ça
vraiment pendant des années des années
je voulais vous dire au revoir au revoir
et bonne chance
vous avez toute notre confiance merci
monsieur le directeur tellement jeune
les voyages forment la jeunesse est un
grand et long voyage que vous commencé
aujourd'hui et quand j'aurai terminé ma
mission dans deux ans dans six ans
disons je ne serai peut-être plus la
cité rose et un peu pessimiste pour un
jour de fête entre pull à la dg ce
serait encore vivant
je touche du bois mais je ne serai plus
là pour vous accueillir ce n'est pas
important
ne sont pas les zones qui compte son
émission
[Musique]
vous venez d'écouter le premier épisode
du podcast espions une vie sous légende
dans le prochain épisode
à quoi ressemble la vie des clandestins
sur le terrain tu peux pas jouer tu
crois totalement unique hui se nourrir
ni clandestins caen joue j'ai toujours
ma femme chez hugo boss veut mourir
le bureau des légendes créée par eric
rochant produit par top-10 oligarques
production fédérations entertainment est
une création originale et canal+
retrouvez tous les épisodes en
exclusivité sur my canal pour continuer
à explorer l'univers du bureau des
légendes
découvrez gratuitement les autres
épisode du podcast espions une vie sous
légende sur my canal apple podcast
google podcast spotify et toutes les
plateformes
ce podcast est produit par thau ziio
ligue arc sédition et canal+ il a été
écrit et réalisé par pauline blistène
samuel dekyndt a assuré la prise de son
basile catelin le montage et le conseil
sonore antoine karachi l'habillage et le
mixage
oui
[Musique]